MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to "Talks at
Google" in Cambridge.
Today it's my great pleasure to
introduce Dr. Edward Baptist,
associate professor
of history at Cornell.
In addition to today's
book, he is the author
of "Creating an Old South--
Middle Florida's Plantation
Frontier Before the Civil
War," and, with Louis Hyman,
"American Capitalism--
A Reader,"
an ebook just released
by Simon and Schuster.
Today marks the beginning of his
tour to discuss his new book,
"The Half Has Never
Been Told-- Slavery
and the Making of
American Capitalism."
Publishers Weekly has said that
this book is, "an unapologetic,
damming, and grisly account of
slavery's foundational place
in the emergence of America
as a global superpower,
balancing the macro lens of
statistics and national trends
with intimate slave narratives.
Delivered in a voice
that fluidly incorporates
both academic objectivity
and coarse language,
Baptist's chronicle
exposes the taint
of blood in virtually all
of the wealthiest Americans
have inherited from
their forebearers."
Please join me in
welcoming Edward Baptist.
EDWARD BAPTIST: Alright,
thanks, and thanks
to Google for having me, and
thank you for showing up.
I appreciate it
and I'm not going
to talk about The Economist
yet, but if you have questions,
I don't think I can avoid them.
I also noticed I
think I might be
the only person in the
building with a tie.
I expected that was
going to be the case,
but my wife just
got this for me,
so I didn't really
have a choice.
Alright, so I think what I'm
going to do is read a passage
and then talk a little bit,
and then read a passage
and have a few
more things to say.
And then, maybe, either one or
two more passages after that,
but I want to leave plenty of
time for questions and answers.
So let me start.
"On a bright spring
Maryland morning in 1805,
Charles Ball rode
comfortably on the board seat
of a wagon, the lead rope
of his owner's yoke of oxen
in his hands.
He was driving the
team to a little town
on the bank of Patuxent River.
Ball's latest owner-- he
had five in his 25 years--
was a hard man.
Mr. Ballard would
make a slave work
in the woods on the snowiest
of days with no boots.
But Ball had hopes.
All through the
neighborhood he was
known as a strong intelligent
worker with a steady temper,
unlike is irascible
African grandfather
or as runaway father.
Charles Ball had been hired
out to the Washington Navy Yard
and had come back
instead of running away
like so many others had done
when they had worked abroad.
Ball could figure out faster,
smarter ways to do any job.
And he had incentives--
a wife and children
owned by another white man.
Balls extra hours supplied his
family with food and clothing,
and though he would later to
laugh at his younger self,
the 25-year-old
Charles Ball hoped
for his own and his
family's freedom.
He was not alone.
In Maryland's decaying
tobacco economy,
enslavers we're allowing
many African Americans
to buy their freedom.
The free constituted 5% of
the state's 111,000 people
of African descent in 1790
and they'd be 22% of 145,000
by 1810.
Maryland was becoming
a middle ground
between the slave
state and a free one."
I go on to explain that
Ball gets to the town
where he's bringing the team
of oxen, ties up the oxen,
and goes to get a
little bit of breakfast,
but he sees his owner standing
outside the stable talking
with another white man.
"Uneasily swallowing
a last mouthful,
Ball stood up and
walked slowly out.
He began hitching up the oxen
fumbling with the leather rope,
suddenly he felt the presence
of several people looming around
him.
He turned as, out of
nowhere, a dozen white men
had surrounded him.
Before his eyes
had time to flicker
from one hard face to another,
his head jerked back as someone
seized him by the
collar from behind.
You are my property now, a
voice shouted in Ball's ear.
And, as he whipped
his head around,
he saw the man with whom
Ballard had been whispering.
You must go to you must
go with me to Georgia,
the stranger snarled."
So I then set what's
happening to Ball
in the context of the
larger migration that's just
beginning-- a forced migration
they would, ultimately,
move a million a enslaved
African Americans from older
parts of the South to what
would become increasingly
larger new parts of the South as
the US acquired more territory.
And I talk over the course is a
book about how the slave trade
to develops, changes,
and grows and becomes,
in fact, the breeding ground
for a lot of innovative business
practices-- for a
lot of market making,
some economists might say,
for a lot of institutions.
They bring buyers
and sellers together,
they make information
flow more freely,
they make credit
all in the name of moving
enslaved human beings.
And I continue to follow
the story of Charles Ball.
I talk about how he is actually
locked into a series of chains
called a cothal,
and how the march
South, with 51 other people
to whom is chained, begins.
And I try to take the
reader into his mind
as he described it many, many
years later-- as these events
were happening.
How he dreamed that night,
as he lay in chains,
that his son came to try to
break the chains but could not.
And how he then dreamed
about his grandfather, who
I mentioned just now, his
African grandfather who had,
in fact, helped Charles's own
father, the grandfather's son,
to escape from slavery so
that he could not be sold.
I follow this story
of Charles Ball
all the way down
the South Carolina
where he sold to a man
named Wade Hampton.
Wade Hampton, who
was at that point
already one of the wealthiest
men in the United States,
and Wade Hampton put Charles
Ball on his cotton plantation.
Now at this point, 1805,
cotton is a relatively new crop
in the United States and it is
just moving into the position
that it eventually comes to
hold in the world economy.
And it holds that position for a
large part of the 19th century.
That position is that of the
world's most widely traded
commodity.
Through most a 20th
century, that position
would have been held by oil.
Through most of
the 19th century,
that was held by cotton.
Cotton was the raw
material that was
used in the factories of the
new industrial system that
was emerging in England
and later in New England.
It was turned into
textiles, textiles
that could be turned
out at a quantity
a of a variety
previously impossible
with traditional modes
of hand manufacture.
And they would slowly
push out other kinds
of textile manufacturing
around the world
and themselves become a
massively important kind
of trade, massively
important commodity that's
shopped all around the world.
In other words, the
cotton is the raw material
of the Industrial Revolution.
It is the raw material in
the early modernization
of the global economy.
And Charles Ball would
be forced to make it.
So, what's significant about how
African Americans make cotton,
starting in the 1790s and going
all the way up into the Civil
War, is the fact that
the cotton they made
pushed other producers
out of the market.
It gradually became
the dominant--
the US South gradually became
the dominant producer of cotton
on the world market.
Whereas it made almost none
at the start of the Industrial
Revolution.
So as the market
for the raw material
is growing dramatically, not
only the ability of the US
South to produce it,
but their market share
is growing dramatically.
And one of the
historical problems
that I try to address in the
book is why that was the case.
One reason is that
huge amounts of land
were taken from Native
Americans, huge amounts of land
were taken, were bought,
from other European powers.
Later from North
American powers were
seized, like the territory
that's taken from Mexico.
Another piece of it,
of how this comes
to pass-- of how this massive
upsurge in US cotton production
comes to pass-- is
the forced migration
of large numbers of
African Americans.
A million people are
moved and most of them
go into making cotton.
And the children, if the
children are born and survive,
go on to making cotton in places
like Alabama, Mississippi,
Louisiana, Texas and so on.
But, another piece
of it is the fact
that the labor process changes,
and it changes continuously
and dynamically on
the cotton frontier.
So in 1805, when Charles Ball
learns how to pick cotton,
he picks about 50 pounds a day.
A few decades later,
the average amount
picked would be two
to four times that.
And one of the historical
problems I try to address
is why that increase happens,
and this is something
that I imagine is going to be
continued subject of debate
between historians
and economists.
But my explanation
ultimately is that enslavers
create a system of
measurement-- they measure
the day's picking of cotton--
and recording information--
they write down the number of
pounds the enslaved person has
picked-- and they then compare
it to a quota, a quota that
is individually determined
based on their past performance.
If they have not met that
quota on that particular day,
they're whipped.
If you've seen the film
"12 Years a Slave,"
you've seen a little bit of
this dramatized on the screen.
And then another piece of
it, when enslaved people
learn how to meet that
quota, that quota is raised.
And so over time, the average
quota of the average slave
gets higher and higher.
The average slave
has to learn how
to meet those higher
and higher quotas.
And that explains why
the price of cotton
in real dollars, raw
cotton, is 15% in 1860 what
it was an 1800, even
though the demand for it
has increased dramatically.
Alright, how did enslaved
people describe that process
that they went through, the
process of being forced,
of being moved-- and we've
heard a little bit of that
from Charles Ball-- and then
the process of being forced
to raise their own
ability to produce
this crucial raw material for
the Industrial Revolution?
Well, at the heart
of my book, I tried
to put the voices of
enslaved people themselves.
This can be hard to do
because, as you may be aware,
literacy was essentially
forbidden for most slaves
in most states,
and, of course, they
didn't have the
tools ready at hand
to write and record
their thoughts.
But, despite that,
we do have access
to the experiences and
the thoughts of formerly
enslaved people because as
people like Charles Ball-- who
was not unique, but very unusual
in that he successfully escaped
from slavery in the deep
South, but there were
other people like him-- as
people like Charles Ball
escape, many of them were able
to find people to help them
write down their memoirs,
create their autobiographies,
and publish them.
And this became the
basis, in many ways,
for the abolitionist
movement that
would ultimately oppose slavery.
They're about hundreds of
those published autobiographies
from the 19th century of
formally enslaved people,
and they're a great
source for studying
what the experience of
slavery was actually like.
On the other hand,
in the 1930s, there
were still thousands of
formally enslaved people alive,
and the federal government,
as part of the Works Progress
Administration, one of these
agencies of the New Deal
that was trying to put
people back to work
hires different individuals--
some of them graduate students,
some of them unemployed
teachers, some of them
locally prominent
spouses of judges,
and so on and so forth--
anybody who had the ability
to go and make connections
with former slaves
was sent out into different
neighborhoods and communities
around the country.
And all in all, about
2,200 interviews
were done with formerly
enslaved people,
and these narratives are
also crucial to the story
that I tell.
I try to put those things
at the center of the story
and, as we can talk about later,
that is in itself, as it turns
out, something of a
controversial act.
Alright, so there was one person
who gave his testimony to a WPA
interview named Henry
Clay-- probably named
after the famous American
politician, born about 1840--
and he told his story to
his interviewer in the 1930s
and I think it's
really interesting.
And he claimed he'd been born
into slavery in the Carolinas
and moved to Louisiana
has as a boy.
And he grew up on
a cotton plantation
in Louisiana, being forced
to work faster and faster.
And he claimed to
his interviewer
that his owner once
possessed a machine, which
by his own account made cotton
cultivation and harvesting
mechanical and
rapid and efficient.
And, by the way, there was
no mechanical cotton picker,
no machine that would do the
job slaves did until the 130s.
It turned out to be a very
difficult engineering problem
to solve, but his
owner supposedly
had a machine that
solved the problem
to some extent, the problem
of how to pick more cotton.
Because, of course, the more
cotton your slaves picked,
the more pounds of
cotton would sell,
the higher your total revenue
would be as a slave owner.
So "this machine was
a big wooden wheel,
as Clay remembered,
with a treadle on it.
And when you tromped
on the treadle,
the big wheel goes around.
On that wheel was four or
five leather straps with holes
cut in them to make blisters.
And you lay the Negro down
on his face, on a bench,
and tie to it.
Now, when the operator pumped
the treadle to turn the wheel,
the straps thrashed the back
of the man or woman tied
to the bench into bloody jelly.
According to Clay, the mere
threat of the whipping machine
was enough to speed
his own hands."
Now, the contraption might
have actually existed,
but I actually think it did not.
I think it was not
a material thing,
but it was actually a metaphor.
I think he saying that every
cotton labor camp carved out
of the Southwestern woods used
torture, used whipping as it
central technology.
And so every day--
with measurement,
with recourse to the
information that was already
recorded about
people's production,
and then with whipping of
those who didn't actually
succeed in meeting their
quota-- calibrated pain
was being used to
push enslaved people
to exceed their previous
day's gains in production.
This was a kind of
technology, a technology
of whips, and measuring
weights, and slate--
where the pounds would be
recorded-- which forced people
to focus their minds on
inventing new ways to perform
repetitive and mind
numbing labor at nearly
impossible speed.
Fingertips hardened, but also
became more subtle and swift.
Enslaved people developed
different tricks,
ways to get down the row
with as little wasted
movement as possible.
Some of their new discoveries
they could teach each other,
but, ultimately, one also had
to-- and you get some of this
from some of the ex-slave
interviews-- they
had to split their own
consciousness in half
in some ways-- to be
present but not be present,
to generate unseen creativity in
movement, new graces of speed.
And this was the
key, I would argue,
to the astonishing increase
of cotton production
over time, which is extremely
important to the creation
of the modern economy.
Because, of course, raw cotton,
at 15% of its earlier price,
enables the factory owners,
who are processing that
into one of the most
important commodities
that they sell-- the
cotton textiles which
go all over the world and
invade all kinds of markets
from India, to China, to
Africa, to Latin America--
it allows them to lower
the price of their product.
It allows them to skim off
revenues and reinvest them
new machines.
It allows them to pay
slightly higher wages
to workers, which dampens
down industrial unrest.
And so the increase productivity
on the cotton plantation
is one of the keys,
one of the keys
that makes all of
those things possible.
Let me transition
to one more reading.
And this reading
brings us to Boston.
This reading brings us from
Maryland, South Carolina,
and Louisiana,
specifically, to Boston.
Boston was closely
linked to the things that
were happening on
the cotton frontier.
And not just because
the textile factories
that boomed, that were so
important to the Massachusetts
economy in Lowell and
other parts of the state,
were-- most of them-- were owned
by men and women who lived here
in Boston.
Well, one of the members
of the class of people
who owned those factories
had a particularly direct
relationship to
Louisiana cotton fields.
And this was a man named
John Gorham Palfry,
and he actually lived
in Louisiana briefly
because his father
John Palfry, the elder,
had been a merchant
in Boston, but then
had bought Louisiana
plantation-- about 1804--
and move down there.
And he moved his five sons, one
of them, John Gorham Palfry,
was the oldest.
And he left Louisiana when he
turned 18 and moved back up
here to go to Harvard.
And at Harvard he was ordained
as Unitarian minister.
He ran a church for awhile,
became a professor of theology.
So he was a Harvard professor.
And then, late in
the 1830s, he took
over a magazine called "The
North American Review."
And the "North American
Review" was a sort
of "New York Review of Books"
or "Atlantic" or something
along those lines of the '30s.
It was the magazine
of a national,
educated middle
class-- published
authors of America's emerging
literature, James Fenimore
Cooper, William Cullen
Bryant, et cetera, et cetera.
His four brothers were
still in Louisiana
and they gradually took over
their father's cotton operation
as he older.
The brothers stayed in
contact and John Gorham Palfry
sometimes went down
to Louisiana to visit.
In the 1830s, he came down,
went back up to Boston,
and he wrote letters
that asked ironically
after individual enslaved people
in terms of racist parody, "How
are my sooty friends?" he wrote.
When William contemplated, one
of his brother's, contemplated
visiting Boston,
John the younger
told him to bring his own slave.
"The free black servants
you can hire here
are good for nothing," he said.
The Palfry's agreed, it
seemed, on slavery and race
as they did on
national politics.
They were both part
of the Whig party.
Well, as John the elder aged--
this is John Gorham's father--
the Louisiana Palfry's took care
to advise their Massachusetts
brothers that under the terms
of the Louisiana civil code--
that's a Napoleonic
form of law--
he would inherit, automatically,
one third of his father's
property.
One of the brothers had
died in the meantime.
Most of the value of that
property was in slaves.
The best way to turn that
share into money usable
in Massachusetts would be to
sell the people he inherited.
"But you might incur
the risk," wrote
one of his brothers, "of some
busy abolitionist reporting
that the Reverend Dr,
Palfry had been selling
human flesh, et
cetera, et cetera.
Or living on the
income of slave labor."
So Boston at this time
was also becoming,
not just the bed of textile
money and textile innovation,
but abolitionist critique
of slavery in the South.
In the autumn of 1843, one of
the season's first cotton ships
arriving in Boston to offload
cotton for Lowell also
brought news from New Orleans.
Old John Palfry had died
and John Gorham Palfry now
owned 20 human beings.
And so at this point,
something unexpectedly happens.
John the younger
decides he doesn't
want any more
money from slavery.
And so he tells
his brother that he
wants to free all of the slaves,
but Louisiana law at that point
will not allow him to do that.
At least not if they
remain in Louisiana itself.
The brothers, the other
brothers, try to talk about it
and they're becoming
increasingly angry at him.
In fact, when they
disagree with him,
he goes around them, sends a
petition to the Louisiana state
legislature for an
exemption to the law,
forbidding the freeing
of slaves who would then
remain in Louisiana near
their families and so on.
One of the brothers writes
angrily back to John,
"The whole story
would be published
in the local paper on Saturday."
Local planters, their
neighbors, would hear it.
They would get questions.
Their neighbors
would think that they
were from a family
of abolitionists.
Meanwhile, proposing
emancipation
for 20 of the people at
their father slave labor camp
would render the
other 40 unmanageable.
They would talk back to
overseers or run to New Orleans
to find a lawyer
for a freedom suit.
Better to let them remain
quietly at work and time
will gradually settle
all difficulties,
one of the brothers insisted.
Don't rock the boat.
But John rocks the boat.
And, eventually, he
travels down the Ohio River
and brings back 17
of the 20 people
who then become part of
Boston's free black community.
And I want to end
with this because it's
a complicated story.
Palfry doesn't seem--
even after his conversion
to not wanting the
profit of slaves
anymore, and being willing to
fight his brothers in this way
to free those 20 slaves-- he
doesn't seem to be particularly
anti-racist by any terms that
we would understand today.
But, despite that,
he does carry out
this act, which was
very difficult for him.
It was costly to him-- not
just in monetary terms,
but in terms of his
relationship to his family.
And even in terms of his
relationship to other Boston
elites, who are by
no means abolitionist
in the early 1840s.
There are people in
his social circle
who stop talking to him,
who stopped inviting him
to the best parties.
He paid a price, certainly
not the kind of price
that Charles Ball paid for
slavery for opposing slavery,
but a significant
price all the same.
And in the book I
try to explore some
of the reasons
why that might be,
the gradual resentment
of some northern elites
against southern political
power which protected slavery.
But I think the essence
of what happened
here, that I want to pull out
in the case of John Palfry,
is that despite the multiple
kinds of cost-- and we have
to acknowledge the
kinds of cost you
pay-- despite the
multiple kinds of cost,
he made a choice in his own
time to forgo those things
and do something that had an
impact that went beyond the 17
people who were freed.
It was a political act.
It was a political act that,
in its own way, as I explore
the book, helped to change
the nature of anti-slavery
in Massachusetts.
So I think the lesson
here is, don't be evil,
which you may have heard before.
But, it's a tough choice.
It's a tough choice
when you're going up
against deeply embedded
social and economic realities.
Deeply embedded social
and economic interests.
And John Palfrey, to his
credit, made that choice.
So I'll stop, and do we
do Q&A at this point?
Thank you, by the way.
AUDIENCE: My curiosity--
so John Palfry
came back up with
17 of his 20 slaves.
What happened to
the other three?
EDWARD BAPTIST: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So part of the story
that I left out
is this-- He goes down to
Louisiana to bring slaves back,
to bring them back as
emancipated people.
And they convinced him--
and this is all 20 of them,
really-- convinced
him that he needs
to wait-- I think it's July
when he goes down there--
he needs to wait to
the end of the year.
Because they had their
own little gardens
that they were able to spend
some time on at the end
of Saturday workday and
over Sunday working on.
And the 1840s cotton
prices are not so good,
and so sometimes they would be
allowed-- not just half the day
on Saturday, but
maybe from 10 AM
on-- to work there
because there's not
so much of an interest in
producing as much cotton
when the prices is so low.
So they have these
crops they're growing
in these little gardens.
And some of them have
cows, some of them
have planted little
patches of cotton
that they're going to
try to sell as well.
And typically enslaved
people did this
so they could get a
little bit of cash
to supplement their rations,
which we usually pretty
bad-- maybe to buy some
ribbon, some buttons, something
like that that went beyond the
sort of standard issue clothes.
But these folks want
to sell what they've
raised at the end of the year
when it's ready to harvest
and bring the money
back up to Boston
with them, because
they don't totally
trust John Palfry, the
son of their slave owner.
They want to have a little
bit of a cash reserve
so that they can
stake themselves
to some kind of independence
when they get up to Boston.
And, in fact, he tries
to place most of them
in different jobs,
usually very menial jobs.
And their tendency is
more to slip off and do
their own thing-- in some
cases, start their businesses.
Well, in that intervening
time period-- and this
gets back your question--
three of the oldest slaves
decide that they want
to stay in Louisiana.
They're all, I
think, over 50, which
is quite old for
enslaved people Louisiana
at that point in time.
And they have children
and grandchildren there.
And those children and
grandchildren had not
been freed, had not been
willed to John Palfrey.
So essentially, the other
brothers cut a deal.
They say, we will let
them live on the fringes
of our plantations, will
understand that they're free,
but we just won't talk about
that to our neighbors too much.
AUDIENCE: So there's an argument
that South was held back
because of slavery
from industrializing
like the North did and
so on and so forth.
But, based on the
subtitle, is sounds
like your thesis
is that slavery is
very important in
American capitalism.
How do you kind of draw
those two together?
EDWARD BAPTIST: So are at
least two different questions,
I think, embedded in that.
I mean, one is, was
the South held back?
And the other-- was
slavery a plus or minus
for American
capitalism in general?
I think for the
second one, I think
I would argue
unquestionably yes.
It brought massive
export earnings
into the United States.
It was 50% of all the
export earnings of US
and, virtually, every year
from 1800 to 1860-- 50%
came from cotton, I should say.
And then, if you added
some of the other crops,
it even creeps a little higher
when you look at slavery share.
Also, because it was exporting
all of these relatively
high value commodities, or
high demand commodities-- let's
put it that way-- created
a circuit of payment
and repayment that brought
huge amounts of credit
into the American economy
on an annual basis.
British investors,
in particular,
and a lot of the world savings
were pulling in Britain
at that point in time.
British investors were
very eager to invest
in that whole circuit
of trade and repayment.
And so other
industries piggybacked
on that stream of credit.
And we could go on
about this, but I
think that there are multiple
ways in which slavery helps
American capitalism in general.
But, it does so at
a tremendous cost.
First of all, to enslave people.
Second of all, I'd
argue, you could argue,
creates winners and losers in
both the North and the South
among free people.
And, potentially,
the whole South
ends up being a loser
because of the commitment
to slavery and to the
production, ultimately, of one
major commodity.
And over the long run,
I think that's true.
I think that's pretty consistent
with the experience of most
regions that invest themselves
so heavily in producing one
commodity no matter how
important that is to the world
economy.
But, as long as the
ride is going well,
it can be a great ride
for the people who
are sitting at the
top of that process.
And when you look
at the way wealth
is distributed among whites
and the United States in 1865,
five of the six
highest states in terms
of per capita wealth for white
people are cotton states.
I always forget the order.
I know Louisiana's
first, and then
you also have-- in that
number you have Mississippi,
and Alabama, Florida, and I
think George's the other one.
But, this produces a very
prosperous upper, and even
a very prosperous middle class.
And they don't have an
incentive to change the system.
Even if over the long run,
we can look back and say
the choices that
were made, the choice
to invest in cash
commodity production,
didn't lead to a sort
of complex local economy
that you saw in Boston,
that you saw in New England
more generally.
You also have to
reckon with in fact
that the Civil War
happened, which
not only stripped the southern
states of 20% of the accounting
wealth, the wealth on the
books of the country-- which
is enslaved people--
and thus left them
at a much lower
position financially
than they had been before.
But, in addition to
that, creates a lot
of physical devastation
throughout the south as well.
I don't say that to say
we should feel sorry
for Southern planters
because of Sherman's March.
They started the war.
They, to my lights, committed
treason against the government,
but it does have
a long term effect
on the future
development of the South.
AUDIENCE: You started
off at the very beginning
by referring, inevitably,
to "The Economist" review.
Obviously, the book is going
to have a certain reception
in the world where there
are established agendas,
but I'm curious in academia.
Among economists and
historians, there's
probably been a lot of research,
an ongoing dialogue over years
and decades that most
of us are unaware of.
Where does this book
and your research
fall then in an ongoing
dialogue and debate?
EDWARD BAPTIST: Now, that's
a really good question.
I think that there are
certainly things about my book
that I, as the author would
argue, are new and innovative.
And I could talk about
them in just a second.
But, at the same time, there
is this long debate about
was slavery capitalists?
To what extent, if
it was capitalistic,
did it contribute to the larger
development of capitalism?
Or perhaps,
alternatively, it was
something that put the
brakes on the development
of the modern economy-- not just
in the South, but elsewhere.
I've laid out where I stand
on the last point, certainly.
But I'm not the only person
who would make the argument
that there are key
things about slavery--
as a set of institutions
and practices,
as a culture-- that make it more
like the rest of the emerging
Western capitalist complex
in the early 19th century
than it is less like.
More alike, more
part of, than it
is different, than
it is separate.
That it is just one flavor in
a larger banquet of capitalism,
and it contributes
to the overall whole.
And there are
number of historians
who would argue that.
There are also some
economists, but I
think that I've already gotten
some push back from economists
who-- whether they're
saying this because it's
sort of a fundamental position
that capitalism must include
free wage labor, must be based
on free wage labor or not.
But they're arguing
that, in fact,
the contribution of
enslaved people's labor
to the development of
capitalism is not so significant
as I make it out to be.
One point in particular
where there's
some debate and
some divergence is,
what is the cause of
that massive increase
in productivity
that I mentioned?
Productivity, of
course, is defined here
as the quantity of labor--
or the quantity of output,
I should say-- the
quantity of output
generated in a given
amount of time.
So the number of pounds picked
in a day by one laborer.
And some economists argue
that the source of that
is improved cotton seeds, and
that this produces a bigger
yield of more pickable cotton.
And I would argue, and
I say this in the book,
that that is
definitely part of it,
but somebody still has
to pick the cotton.
There's more cotton out there,
and it's easier to pick.
It's probably not four
times easier to pick.
There's still a lot
of moving, a lot
of grabbing, a lot of pulling.
And, in fact, slave
owners also seem
to think that it's not the seed
that they need to focus on,
but it's actually extracting
the labor from individuals.
So every day, and this goes
back to the description
of the sort of calibrated
system that I mentioned
before, every day
they're weighing.
Every day they're recording
the amount of weighed.
And every day, if you listen
to what formally enslaved
people say, they're whipping
those who come up short.
And this is a big
complicated system
to put in place if what's really
making a difference is seeds.
Enslavers really believe that
it is the pushing, the weighing,
the whipping that is making
the difference in output
and increasing
productivity over time.
But you don't know
that if you don't
look at what formally
enslaved people say.
If you just look at what
the owners are saying,
you just look at output--
and some economists
have had a tendency--
then you don't really
understand what the labor
system is like from the inside,
from the perspective of
those who experienced it.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
when you started out,
what was your aspiration,
what did you have in mind?
Do you feel like
you achieved that,
and where would
you go from here?
EDWARD BAPTIST: So
that's a good question.
Yeah, it was a while
ago when I started
really working on this project.
Google was one of
many search engines.
I wasn't familiar with Google
Maps, it might have existed.
One of my students
was trying to convince
me to use a search
engine called "Dog Pile."
I don't think, I
mean, maybe that's
still out there on the way
back machine or something.
But it was a long time ago.
And the project
really grew over time
because I wanted to look just
at the experience of people
like Charles Ball.
And I just wanted to tell their
story of moving from point A
to point B. But,
as I dug into that,
I realized that
that was connected
to virtually everything else
that happened in the South
from 1790 to 1860,
which is a long time.
And everything that happened
there, it turned out,
was connected to US
politics, national expansion,
to the growing cultural
sense of the United States--
with a separate culture
that people like John Palfry
were a part of.
There were many, many
connections, of course.
That's a wonderful thing.
That's a kind of experience of
wealth and excitement, right?
You're seeing all of the
connections in the world.
And, at the same time, you have
tell a story behind two covers,
right?
And has some kind of
coherent structure.
So that was the struggle that I
went through-- not just reading
all the sources, of
which there were many,
but figuring out how to not
read some sources, if you will,
that maybe in some
alternate universe where
I have infinite
time could be part
of an infinitely large story.
So what's next?
I have a couple of projects
that I'm working on,
but, I think-- I was talking
to a couple friends of mine.
I said, well I'm going
to go talk to Google.
And they said, well,
maybe you don't
say capitalism
comes from slavery.
And I said, well, I don't know.
I'm not quite sure
what people at Google
think about those
kinds of questions
so I'll just talk about it.
But, they did urged me to
talk about another project
I'm working on
because it directly
connects the amazing
digital tools that we all
have now to the study history.
So one of the things that
when I was doing research
on this project I always
wanted to have, one of things
always wanted to
have was a collection
of runaway slave ads,
a full collection.
I don't know if you've
ever seen these things,
if you've read Frederick
Douglass's autobiography,
he discusses them.
Other fugitive slaves
talk about them.
Even "Huckelberry Finn" sort of
tangentially talks about them.
So when an enslaved person ran
away in the antebellum South,
often the owner would place
an ad in a local newspaper.
And this ad was very
frank in many cases,
because it had to physically
describe the person.
So, Jim-- five foot
nine, 27 years old.
That description
not only is richer
than a lot of the
description we have
in any sort of systematic way
about large numbers of slaves,
but it might then
also go on to say,
Jim-- three of whose fingers
on his right hand were cut off,
whose back is much scarred with
whips, et cetera, et cetera.
And it might describe their
clothes, where they came from.
Jim was just moved from South
Carolina to Alabama a year ago,
may be trying to get back.
Things like that.
So there's amazing
detail and there
are amazingly large
numbers of the sources.
My vague estimate is that there
are probably about 100,000
of them out there
in newspapers that
survived, because
the early 1800s is
the era of another new
technology-- the steam
powered press.
And newspapers proliferate.
They stop being weeklies and
become two or three times
a week, and they become dailies.
Newspapers are everywhere.
And runaway ads are in
most of the Southern ones.
So my mind guesstimate is
that there are about 100,000.
I don't think I'm off by a
whole order of magnitude.
I know not on the
low end, anyway.
We already have gathered
over 10,000 of them.
But what I want
to do is not just
gather them and put
them in digital form--
collect them as a
whole bunch of PDFs--
but, what I also
want to do is create
a database that categorizes
the information.
And we're going to use
a relational database
as sort of an underlying
structure there-- categorizes
the information
that's in those ads.
The name, the height,
where they ran from,
how many times this
ad ran, and so on.
So that you can do all kinds
of interesting analysis.
And we will also record all
the text, which will allow us,
hopefully, if we
get enough text,
to do some very interesting
text mining with it.
And, in fact, one of
the people that I'm
working with at
Cornell's library
wants to run-- this has probably
already occurred to a lot you--
but basically the
same kind of analysis
with a relational database
as with the text mining,
and see if you've got radically
different kinds of results--
see if the difference might tell
you anything about the ability
or the usefulness of
different text mining tools
and techniques.
And then the other
piece of this database
is that I want a large part
of it to be crowdsourced.
So we're building a
site where hopefully,
if we continue to get funding
over the next couple of years,
we'll be able to create
an experience for users--
students, in particular,
are one of our targets--
where they will go
to the site and then
be presented with
a runaway slave ad,
and their job will be to do
the detective work of pulling
information out of
that ad, recording it
for us in the
relational database,
maybe correcting a
transcription of the text.
And as they do that, they
will be building and deepening
our database.
And we think the kinds
of historical analysis
we can do with this will
be significantly more
effective and more interesting
than a lot of the work we've
been able to do so far
in slavery studies.
So that's the next project.
AUDIENCE: That's
pretty interesting.
I have a question that's on
a different subject though.
I'm wondering if you've done
much comparative analysis
of slavery in the South
with slavery elsewhere.
I'm thinking, in
particular, of, I guess,
the two most obvious
examples would
be the slavery in the
Caribbean for the purpose
of harvesting sugar and
also the slavery of Indians,
in particular, say Peru
earlier by the Spanish, too,
for mainly for the
purpose of mining--
those, in particular the Spanish
system, seems pretty different.
Also seems, pretty
clearly, not too
have led to any sort of
industrial capitalism at all.
I guess, for the British
system in the West Indies,
you'll probably have to
look at how that related
to industrialization
in Britain more,
and I know there's a lot of
literature on that already.
But, anyway, I'm just
wondering, just in general,
do these kind of
comparisons tell you
anything about your own theory?
Do they support it?
Do they tend to not support it?
how do you look at that?
EDWARD BAPTIST: Now
that's a great question.
And I don't know so much about
the systems of forced labor
that are used on native
peoples in the Andes,
for instance, to get silver.
But, my basic understanding
is that they're not,
strictly speaking,
chattel slavery.
That they're sort of labor
requisition processes.
The difference If you were
working in the silver mine
might have been pretty hard,
you know, to parse out.
And there were African slaves
working in Peru, sometimes
in the mines, in a sort of more
chattel slavery formulation.
Slavery in the British West
Indies, which ends in 1834,
is already, I would say,
moribund by the early 1800s.
And one reason is
that the productivity
of sugar production
is not increasing.
It hasn't increased in a while.
And there's always been a
sort of a historical problem
or debate about why that is.
Does it have to be
do with labor supply?
The Atlantic slave trade is
cut off in 1808 by Parliament.
Maybe it's easier
to force Africans
into harder kinds of
labor because they're not
able to build the
kind of networks that
allow group and individual
resistance to locally born
enslaved people.
There are a lot of
questions still about that.
But, one thing's for
sure, both the mechanics
of sugar processing and
the way that sugar labor
is extracted from
individuals are
different in Cuba in the 19th
century than what prevailed
in Britain and some other
colonies in the 18th century.
So new machinery comes in,
and sugar is, mechanically
speaking, the most complex
of any commodity production
process before--
I mean, you could
argue it's actually more complex
than the Bessemer process
for making steel--
but it's more complex
than any sort of
chemical process--
so its any non medical
process-- than anything
that happens before
the late 19th century.
It's very important for sugar
slavers to have a lot of credit
so that they can invest
in this kind of machinery,
and the kind of machinery
they have is very important.
Well, they're lot of key
inventions in the 1810s,
'20s and '30s which
allow a speedup
in the processing of sugar.
This is significant because
there's kind of a bottleneck--
if you don't mill sugar, if you
don't then refine the juice you
get from the mill within
about 24 to 48 hours
it starts to go bad.
So unless you have
many, many sugar mills,
there's a limit to how
much labor you can actually
profitably use on
one sugar plantation.
The change that's driven by
these mechanical, technological
innovations leads to
a dramatic increase
in the size of sugar plantations
once they're created on Cuba.
And that primarily begins
to happen after 1834,
after the British emancipation.
So in Cuba, the sugar
plantations get much bigger,
get much more sped up, and labor
is then behind the processing.
So labor in the fields
is slower than what's
happening in the
processing centers.
So labor in the fields
is then sped up,
and they actually,
the enslavers is Cuba,
actually use some
techniques that
are very similar to what
happens in cotton fields
to get people to plant,
and to cut, and to harvest
more rapidly.
And at the same
time, similar things
are happening in
Brazilian coffee
where you have a massive
increase in production
in new territory, often
with new slaves who
had been moved a
very long way away.
It's very similar to cotton.
And the weighing and the
recording of how much slaves
individual slaves have picked in
terms of weight of coffee beans
is very important to pushing
an increase in production.
It might seem like
coffee's not really related
to industrialization,
but I bet I can walk you
through that process really
quickly when you think
about the espresso
machine, right?
I mean, I'm serious.
The transition from
drinking alcohol at work
to drinking coffee work is key
to industrialization as well.
So the Jamaican
example, for instance,
is a little-- it
fits into a longer
story of slavery and
industrialization.
It's bigger than just the USA.
AUDIENCE: I've got a
couple more questions.
First, on the topic
of not being evil,
you suggested--
what you're saying--
I'm sure, what you written--
that in the early 1800s if you
were opposed to slavery,
it would have been very
difficult in the US,
and maybe in the world,
to unplug from the slave
economy from the economics
effects of it.
Can you think of examples,
other than the Civil War itself,
of course, that were
effective at that time
in bringing an end
to slavery in the US.
Particularly, things
that were effective
on an economical level.
And then, my second
question, is can you actually
talk about "The Economist"
review, the response to that,
and so forth?
EDWARD BAPTIST: I can try
to answer both of those,
but when you ask effective
at ending slavery in the US,
do you mean in, let's say
local emancipation-- like what
you have in the
Northern states--
or do you mean effective
in ending slavery
in other societies
beyond the US?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think both in a sense,
in that if what
you found offensive
was the act of slavery
itself and it was
offensive in your
country and elsewhere.
EDWARD BAPTIST: OK.
So explaining abolition
and explaining
why the British abolished
slavery has launched
all sorts of history
books, right?
It's spilled a lot of
ink, and there's still
a lot of debate about that.
And there's two points of view.
One is that it was an act
of what one historian calls,
"econocide," right?
So it was economically
very healthy for Britain
to have sugar
plantation colonies
where the labor
was done by slaves,
and they abolished slavery as
a sort of act of generosity,
of moral goodness, if you will.
And you can nuance that and
say, well they weren't really
so good after all.
They actually were hoping
for something else,
but that's the essential point.
The other is to argue-- and
this goes all the way back
certainly to the
1940s, but maybe
even before-- to argue
that capitalism in Britain
was changing dramatically
by the early 1800s,
as evidenced by the
Industrial Revolution.
And a heavy investment in the
slave trade, in Atlantic slave
trade-- it was necessary to
populate sugar plantations
because people died
at an astonishing rate
on sugar plantation,
so you had to go
more slaves-- and
the investments
in the sort of
institutional power,
that you had the seed
to sugar planters.
That this was a limiting
force, a sort of parking
brake on the development
of industrial capitalism
in Britain itself.
And so it's not an
act of econocide,
it's an act of
economic self love
on the part of the
British ruling class
to abolish slavery.
The story, I think, is--
there's a little bit of both,
and it's much more
complicated at the same time.
If you look at other societies,
what you typically find
is that they abolish
slavery because they
had to, because they
were forced to do so.
So African countries,
or African societies,
where slavery actually
grows in the 1800s
because the European market for
the products those slaves make
is all of a sudden getting
much larger because
of industrialization-- those
societies only abolish slavery
in the late 19th century
because they're forced to.
They're forced to by the
British, in particular.
Brazil abolishes
slavery very late, 1888,
and it does so because
it's been effectively
isolated-- it's been isolated
by the fall of the South--
and pressure from its main
trading partners, Britain
and the US.
And, at the same
time, Brazil also
has sort of lucked into a
really, really good stream
of labor coming in the form of
essentially indentured servants
who are traveling from Italy--
Italy which is, at that point,
impoverished.
So they don't completely have to
at that point, they're not 100%
backed into it, but there's
some pretty strong incentives,
pretty strong pressures,
being put on them.
And then, of course, in
the case the US, slavery
ends because of war--
and a war that's
started by enslavers themselves.
Now, one question
that always comes up
is, well, would slavery have
ended without the Civil War?
And, on that point,
people who have
tried to answer that question
often say, well, of course.
Slavery would've ended.
It's just so premodern,
it would have had to end.
Well, it's 2014 and there
are slaves in our world.
There are people
who are enslaved.
There are people who
are enslaved in Boston.
They're not legally enslaved,
but they're effectively
enslaved.
And their labor, which is
primarily domestic labor,
is very profitable.
And then when you go
beyond the United States
and beyond the West,
you find places
where forced labor is pretty
open-- in parts of Africa,
and Central Asia, and so on.
So, I'm not ready to concede
that slavery would have simply
had to end because it was
so premodern, or whatever.
It seemed to be
pretty well integrated
into the modern economy.
Maybe after the invention
of mechanical cotton picker
we would've seen
an end to slavery,
but, of course, slavery
had been adapted
to a new product in the past.
Now, alright, "The Economist."
I learned that "The
Economist" would
be reviewing my book
a couple weeks ago,
and I didn't anticipate
that it would be a rave.
But I anticipated it would be a
kind of a thoughtful engagement
that looked at the recent
scholarship as well as mine,
and tried to put my book
in the context of that.
That's, for instance, what
"The Wall Street Journal" did
and it reviewed-- it
came out this week.
And it put my book in the
context of other people
who are writing about
slavery and capitalism,
like Walter Johnson here
at Harvard-- here in town
at Harvard-- who's written
a great book, essentially,
on slavery capitalism--
came out last year.
That's not what "The
Economists" did.
"The Economist"
chose to charge me
with writing a history that
was advocacy and not objective.
We could debate about what
objectivity in history is.
I'm not sure what they
think I'm advocating,
but-- if I'm
advocating anything--
I think I'm advocating that
at the center of any story
about slavery
should be sources--
and we're lucky in
the US that they're
pretty voluminous-- these
sources that are created
by the survivors
of slavery, that
are the testimony of the
survivors of slavery.
It doesn't mean that's the
only source we look at.
It's not the only
source I look at,
but it's a source that
can't be dismissed,
and too often, in the
writing of slavery history,
has been pushed to the
side and made secondary.
And this-- if I can read "The
Economist" review correctly--
seemed to be the thing that
enraged the reviewer the most.
I seemed, to their
mind, to be privileging
those stories, and
that, because I
put African American
testimony about slavery
at the center of the story,
that made it a kind of advocacy.
I also think that's the sort
of chain of criticisms that
enraged a lot of
respondents to the review,
because I got the review on
Thursday-- about one or two
o'clock Eastern time-- and
by late that night, I think,
we were five full pages of
comments on "The Economist"
site, and every single
one of them that I saw
was profoundly negative.
And some of them were quite
incisive and quite smart
and by the next
morning, "The Economist"
had pulled the review
with a partial apology.
I could say some things
about how they used the image
of Lupita Nyong'o,
which, I think,
was pretty reprehensible,
the way that they did it.
And they haven't
apologize for that either.
But it turned out to
be great publicity
for any discussion of
capitalism and slavery.
I mean, I got-- the phone
was ringing off the hook.
They sold a lot of
books, and I hope
they sold a lot of other
books about slavery
for some of my friends.
And I hope people are going
to talk about these issues
more, because, I think, the
reaction of "The Economist"
showed that the issue is still
alive in a lot of quarters.
And discussion of the influence
of slavery on how we live today
is something that's going
to provoke some deep,
searching questions, I
think, for all of us.
So, hopefully, that's--
hopefully questions will be
deepen and searching.
Not everybody thought that
"The Economist" review
was deep and searching.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
reading Piketty's "Capitalism
in the 21st Century."
It strikes me that part
of Piketty's thesis
is that capitalism seems to
be, under some circumstances,
you produce greater
and greater wealth
for a smaller and
smaller number of people
and the working class ends up
getting poorer and poorer--
at which point,
slavery kind of seems
like the limiting case of that.
I was trying to
formulate a question
and I have failed
utterly, but any thoughts
about how that pertains
to models of capitalism
and how it evolves over time?
EDWARD BAPTIST: Yeah,
I'm not sure if you
fail to formulate
a question or not.
I think what you did was
open up a whole area, right.
Which is really,
really interesting.
And I read-- I can claim
with full truthfulness
to have slogged
through the whole book,
but I wouldn't actually
say it was a slog.
If you read-- if you get into,
like, the last 200 pages,
he's got some really interesting
things to say about the US.
And I'm pretty sure all of
we're pretty successful at US
or other universities,
and there's
some really interesting
things to say
about the kinds of universities
that a lot of you all went to
and that I teach at and
so on, which are rough.
I mean, they are
rough criticisms
and, I think, ones we
have to take seriously
about the role of wealth and
governing them in certain ways.
But anyway, I think one
of the points he makes
is that most human
societies, and certainly
most Western societies since
the Industrial Revolution,
seem to be arenas for the
concentration of wealth
rather than the
democratization of wealth.
Yes, standards of
living on the whole
rise, but they don't
rise nearly as quickly
as they do in
those brief windows
where the
democratisation of wealth
is really sort of running wild.
And there are really
only two moments
where he sees that happening.
One is most of the West
between World War II and 1968,
or maybe between some point
the Great Depression and 1968.
And the other-- and that's
sort of a high inflation
period, which is
part of his argument,
too-- but the other
one is the US North
between the Revolution
and the Civil War.
And that's also unusual.
It's an unusual time and
place, just like the West
as it goes through the
Depression, World War
II, and then the Great Rebuild--
well at the same time you
had this confrontation with
the Eastern Bloc, which
is not incidental to the story.
But the US North is also weird
because, on the one hand,
it can draw a lot
of sustenance, I
would argue, from
the slave South.
It partakes in the
circulation of credit
that is partly
driven by the South
and by the willingness
of British investors,
especially, to send
money into the US
because it'll come back
multiplied through the cotton
trade.
But the North, of course,
isn't weighed down in the ways
or isn't limited in the
ways that slavery clearly
can limit and constrain
choices for an economy.
And then, there's
all that cheap land.
There's all that
free land, right?
It's not really
free because it has
to be taken from the people
who already live on it,
but its there.
So these are two
unusual cases, OK?
So what does this mean for
thinking about the slave South?
What it means is that the
slave South is more like 2014
US, 2014 Western Europe, 1914
Europe than the free North is
like those societies,
in some measures, right?
In some ways.
Certainly when we look at the
way wealth is concentrated.
The profile of the
South is much more
like we are today than
the antebellum North is
like the United States today.
And that's a sobering
thought, right?
And I think there are a
lot of places we could go
and there are ways to take
that analysis a little further,
but I think what it means
is that-- certainly I
read Piketty, and I find
a lot of richness there,
a lot of interesting thoughts
for thinking about the slave
South and for maybe
building future analyses.
Thank you.
Thanks for your questions.